Hello Freak bitches.
You know the other question is how much of a vitamin do you need?
And I think that people uh,
you know,
buy vitamins indiscriminately cause we really don't.
I like the average person doesn't need to take a multivitamin in the day if
they're eating a,
you know,
a healthy diet cause you get pretty much what you need on a daily basis if
you're not somebody with an absorption issue.
If you're not somebody with a,
any like any dietary issues,
you're generally getting what you need out of your diet.
I think people do it.
If your diet is really healthy,
it's,
most people do not have a really healthy diet.
Most people are getting about what they need out of their diet.
Like seriously it's,
I mean if we have the,
some of the poorest darts or people are just eating process bullshit.
Well no it's even if you go to the doctor and get average person,
I'm guessing you eat fairly healthy.
It's what the average person that they go to the doctor to see if they're
deficient on everything,
on anything they're not going to be deficient on.
I've gone and gotten my blood work done.
Several deficiencies,
Niacin,
vitamin D now I've been before.
But that was right when I was diagnosed with CELIAC disease.
So I was,
I,
I was deficient on a few things.
But you know,
that's an issue with we have an issue absorbing food.
Yeah.
So I mean,
now,
well now that I've been,
it was,
I was at the skinniest point in my life and then I stopped eating wheat and I
gained weight.
So because suddenly you're your bill.
I kind of,
you know,
they,
they heal and you're her able to absorb calories.
Again,
have a friend who's got a son who they was trying to figure out why he was so
small,
he couldn't eat and he was never hungry and eat,
everything is miserable and he's got a wheat allergy.
He's got a corn allergy.
Jesus,
everything was just making him miserable.
I mean,
I got quote unquote lucky.
I only got symptoms when I was in adults.
Uh,
and it was,
you know,
all throughout your childhood years.
No problem,
no problem.
And I mean,
I was even overweight,
uh,
as,
as a kid.
So then when I was an adult,
suddenly horrible symptoms showed up.
I wasn't at work.
Do they have an idea of Celiac?
A Celia can show up,
are the symptoms of it can shoot.
Like you always have the underlying physiology or um,
and just all of a sudden symptoms can just show up out of the blue and then all
of a sudden it becomes,
I mean I kind of,
I had a bunch of health decisions cause to kind of show up in my twenties and I
mean I started,
I'm like,
all right,
I got to start taking care of myself,
started going to the gym,
run a few marathons,
lost a lot of weight.
And like,
even when I was suddenly at a healthy weight,
it was like I couldn't stop losing weight because my,
uh,
my intestines just worn,
absorbing anything.
And that's not a,
that's not a thing you see coming or like I'm at a healthy,
why isn't this stopping?
And it was not good.
But you know,
eventually it was funny because the gluten trend or the anti gluten trend had
already showed up.
And a doctor suggested to me,
well,
have you tried going gluten free?
And I'm like,
oh,
that's a silly fad.
Three months later,
Tyco,
celiac disease.
I'm like,
if I hadn't been so skeptical of everything,
gluten free is a fad.
I don't think gluten is the best thing for your body.
I think that it's okay every now and then,
but I think that essentially what you're getting when you're eating processed
grains is you're getting something.
Your body is key.
It's kind of alien.
The Bondi doesn't exactly know what to do with it.
Well,
there doesn't seem,
here's things.
Tests keeps showing.
There doesn't seem to be a problem with gluten.
If you don't have celiac disease and it's,
what does that mean by a problem?
Is it like for optimizing your health?
Is it something that you should have in your diet all the time?
Or is it something that mean it really does convert to sugar?
It's right.
Everything converts to sugar.
Your body converts everything in some way,
shape or form into usable fuel.
And the usable fuel is,
you know,
eventually glucose or nad ph or,
um,
there's everything in your body gets converted to sugar when you use feel,
but if you eat a piece of salmon or if he had a bowl of pasta is a very
different reaction.
How your body absorbs these two things.
It's a,
yes,
this is,
this is true because all calories aren't,
aren't the same,
right?
They don't both get absorbed to sugar,
but avoiding gluten and switching over to say,
uh,
you know,
all rice,
uh,
isn't,
you know,
that's not going to change,
uh,
far the,
all that much in your body in terms of what's in terms of the biochemical
mischief.
Unless you have a gluten allergy,
like that's,
or not a good analogy.
Yeah.
Seeing the sensitivity's but there's,
there's also level,
so that too,
right?
Like there's some people where it's like mildly,
minorly irritating and there's some people that have extreme issues with it.
Well,
here's at this point,
and this is why I always say at this point in our scientific knowledge,
scientific knowledge can evolve and we can learn new things.
Uh,
you know,
at one point,
the thing that started off the whole gluten trend,
uh,
was uh,
kind of poorly a poorly designed study where they had a small sample size of
people and they designed it just to test,
you know,
gluten versus a non,
a diet without gluten.
And they came to the conclusion that about 20% of people just based on this very
small study had a bad reaction to gluten now pretty well.
And these people had came in saying they had stomach problems.
Now these people,
it turned out,
they looked at it and said,
there's no,
there's no afterwards assigned to Saul sat back and said,
why we're only about 1% of people having celiac disease.
And then all of a sudden 20% of people are running around like glutens making
their Dick flies off a fly off.
This is,
there's something up here.
So they made a better design study and they took out common core.
They did,
you know,
kind of double blind did a a a better design study to say we're going to take
out all these other causes of gastrointestinal distress and we're going to try
and make this double blind.
And they figured out it was the fodmaps it was,
there were these short chain illegal saccharide second pull water into the gut
and cause some gastrointestinal distress.
And it was really closer to between like one at about 5% of people that were
having any issues with gluten.
Now the problem is that what was causing that though the,
the gastrointestinal distress in the smell and the one to 5% so 1% is celiac
disease for sure.
1% his across the board with people.
1% is silly.
That is fairly high.
Now here's the thing that that higher of people that two to five,
here's the question,
now they're still trying to figure out why some people seem to have an issue
with gluten.
Now I could be wrong on,
this is just off the top of my head,
what I remember from the study,
but I've had decided a few times.
So I think my knowledge is accurate.
Uh,
feel free to fact check me out at home.
Um,
but the,
um,
the thing with those extra percent,
they're trying to figure out why they might have an issue with gluten because
they,
you know,
like wheat is,
you think of it as a carb heavy thing,
right?
And gluten is a protein a,
so that other few percentage of people,
they're trying to figure out why the gluten does it cause gluten is in a few
other things.
It's in barley,
raw and rye.
Uh,
so what they figured out is that,
or this is the going theory right now,
uh,
gluten can cause a small,
reaction in the stomach where you produce this protein called Zonulin that can
cause an increase in inflammation.
This seems to be,
and this is what I,
this has only been one study that I've read on it.
It seems to be relatively new.
They're still looking into it.
So there's a chance that people might be in the two to 5% that can handle it.
Because if that,
um,
it could be another component of the wheat,
barley,
rye that's causing it,
but gluten in and of itself,
it's not,
you know,
it's,
unless you are one of those people that has an actual reaction to it,
perfectly fine.
Go on to have,
you know,
go have a sandwich.
So,
but you know,
if you want one
[inaudible].